for millions of families around the
country the cost of living has gone from
being an economic abstraction to a
living Obsession changing our way of
life in ways we haven't experience for
Generations just ask the Dowler family
that's outrageous it's a gradual
change of Lifestyle it wasn't an
overnight thing it's like okay we're
gonna change our shopping style okay
we've got it
reduce our visits for petrol okay you
know the bills have gone up the the
mortgage has gone up you know our
savings are going down we do go around
with a calculator in our hand yes make
sure we're actually sticking to budget
which we didn't do before yeah we talked
about it I don't know yeah when the kids
are in bed
um but in all honesty yeah it's it's
it's it's a worrying time yeah
while inflation fell in April it's not
falling as fast as the bank of England
would like so it's now expected to raise
interest rates even further perhaps as
high as 5.5 percent to bring prices
under control
now five and a half percent interest
rates may not sound very high and if you
look back at the history of interest
rates you can see it's only the highest
level since 2008 but here's the thing
you need to adjust for the fact that
people these days are more indebted they
have lower incomes versus their mortgage
payments adjust for all that and it's a
very different picture you can see that
the adjusted interest rate of five and a
half percent is the highest it's been
since 1991. back then those rates
precipitated a housing crash and a
serious recession
things might not get quite that grisly
this time around but it's a reminder of
the pressures facing households and
businesses in the food sector prices are
still rising at Double Digit rates close
to 20 percent producers like the
sandwich makers say it's coming at them
from all angles if we took a chair to
plowman's that we just saw being made
you've got the bread and that's driven
by the wheat price but if you think of
the bakery they've got their energy
costs they've got their people cast
you've got the cheddar and and we've
seen Dairy double in price so it's it's
really significant so then you've got to
package it and of course paper prices
have gone up and then you've got to get
all the materials delivered here and
you've got fuel and you've got Logistics
costs so it's all those hidden things
there is still some good news here food
prices may now have peaked Energy prices
certainly have the problem is when you
strip out all this volatile stuff core
inflation is still creeping higher the
cost of living crisis is not over yet at
Conway Sky News